here are the latest calls between former
President Obama and president Trump
hello hey Barack I gotta say I don't
know how you put up with all the
criticism the press is that tearing me
apart they're twisting my words and
making it sound like it anti-terrorism
bill is anti-muslim Donald given the
countries you signed out it very much
looks like you're targeting Muslims
that's ridiculous
if that was the case I put whatever
country you're from on the list Donald
we good I was born in Hawaii okay hello
I'm Iraq how'd you like my speech at the
National Prayer Breakfast hated it
you made a mean joke about Celebrity
Apprentice at what was supposed to be an
event for prayer
are you kidding come on I did great I
moved everyone to pray everyone there
was on the news yelling please God save
us day plans it's none of my business
be a pal is there a romantic restaurant
near here where I can get a table for
two
I know this cute little French place
branch Vladimir prefers Italian
rewriting the book on yourself are
policies to be frank and seems like
you're just continuing a lot of them
sanctions on Iran warning Israel not to
build settlements demanding Russia leave
Crimea
yeah but Australia we're going to hit
those dingo lovers so hard don't think
it's winter in the summer actually
they're in the southern hemisphere they
do have winter in the summer yeah I'm
talking about nuclear winter Jesus have
you seen a bear it's been one executive
order after another yeah kind of odd you
didn't approve of presidents issuing
executive orders back when I was doing
it that's cause I didn't know how much
what it was I was making college of
people Japanese you can't
excited businesses Odeon - I'm so smart
doesn't really seem like it get this I
put in three tweeting toilets in the
White House tweeting : yeah I always
like to tweet while sitting on a toilet
it's tough time I want to tweet but I
don't have to drop a Duke so I just put
these sweet soy legs with no plumbing no
water just toilets for me to sit on and
that's what you're on now no actually
I'm on a real toilet I just went oh crap
about a sweep door Gary
[Applause]
you